When we went over the toxins, tests, I registered super high for one used as a flame retarded.
I can't recall the name at the moment.
I've been racking my brain, trying to figure out how I got so much of it since we don't have
any newer carpeting or a new car, etc. I get my hair colored at a beauty shop, do you know if there
could be a connection there? You have any info on your website about safe hair color?
That would be a good question. I don't know that I have any information on our website.
You could search it hair color. I don't know that I have any information on our website about that.
Could there be that chemical that is used in spotted flavor terms in hair dye?
I don't, but anything is possible. What else could have flame retarded chemicals in it?
Well, pretty much any clothing, any furniture, any fabric is going to have flame retarded chemicals
in it. So any of those things, so all your new clothing is going to have that.
So unless you're buying organic cotton clothing, most likely it's going to be sprayed with flame
retarded. You could do a search on that chemical and find look for Google search and search sources
and you could get a pretty good idea where it could be hidden in something as well.